as many of you are aware there were
devastating fires in Maui and they're
saying it may have been caused by
electrical lines not completely sure
many people lost their lives so we hope
everybody's safe hearing from a lot of
people that they have friends and family
they've still not heard from so again I
hope I hope everybody's gonna be okay
and also hearing that the devastation is
worse than even we realized but from
this we had a conversation last night
about this video that went viral earlier
this year of lasers being fired from
satellites over Hawaii and we talked
about there's a conspiracy conspiracy
theory going around well now there's a a
darker and more pervasive conspiracy
theory I should say it's it's spreading
a conversation about direct energy
weapons now there's a lot of a lot of
videos that are completely fake that are
going around but I think it's an
interesting conversation to talk about
the future of warfare because at the
same time there's massive flooding
happening in China the reality is
fires probably started for natural
causes because fires happens all the
time Great Chicago Fire happened cow
kicked over a lantern or whatever it is
you want to believe and uh floods happen
because there's Heavy Rain probably